they're not the best they're the most
creative
no they're not
set
go
I already know that fat chick's going
down first I already know
no way no way
okay okay
these other girls fight about everything
and at the end of the day I get it's a
competition I get we want the money I
know we want to get signed but
you also need to have friends and
alliances and if everyone's just going
to keep fighting I'm just going to stick
with Kaylee and who knows we'll probably
be the last two standing and maybe
they'll sign us both together because
who doesn't want a pair of Besties
why why do you guys do this to me
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel ring
that notification Bell like the video
let's get to 2 000 likes on this video
also guys guys get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt all right you
already know all this craziness is all
from letting women make our own
decisions so get rid of it repeal the
19th the link is in the description at
the audacity Network dot store all right
so today I'm going to be reacting to
another cam House episode so I don't
know why you guys torture me with
watching these low IQ chicas you know
these crazy ladies talk
um but I get I guess you guys liked it
so you know this is a show about women
competing to be a top cam girl you know
I grew up on The Bachelor or at least
they sold the idea of love you know I
mean they never really found it as you
you know would see in those shows they'd
always break up but at least like the
goal was good good not now now it's
these crazy ladies
um competing to be a top cam cam chick
um but you know whatever uh let's let's
pull this video of Awesomeness it felt
amazing to be the first one in the house
I was so thrilled I love my alone time
so it was so nice to be the first one in
the home to look at the beautiful home
and see all the beautiful things inside
of it
thank you
well first of all the house is gorgeous
Tick Tock is going viral all these
emojis they're hurting you and sending
you gifts and coins and she took my
phone and she tried to purposely
sabotage my tech reviewed your Tick Tock
Challenge and we know who the winner and
the losers are and who is going to get
beds and who's not going to get beds
this week so the winner of this
challenge is
[Applause]
it made me feel really happy because I
thought I wasn't going to be able to win
and I did win you're going to be getting
the master suite upstairs and the room
was amazing it's like the perfect room
for me it came with a bunch of books
inside and I really needed to be alone
yeah so last week they had a tick tock
challenge so it was really tough really
tough hard competition I love my alone
time so it just made me feel awesome
like I really kind of want to see you
[Music]
we will see all of you in the next
challenge
it made no sense to me at all I mean I
think the host probably like forgot my
name or something because I definitely
should have won I mean it was all about
me karma is a [__] and she got exactly
what was coming to her and I ended up
getting my own room for the week
honestly Liliana needs to change her
attitude I'm like I'm jealous of you
guys because four girls in one room
that's like having a slumber party every
single night right I'm so excited
maybe she should sleep in the shower
maybe you should you're jealous I have
to sleep on the floor I don't even get a
bed this is
I think Naomi's opening up and maybe by
the end of this even if she doesn't win
she might be able to have a personality
and actually have friends for one I mean
I don't have a lot of friends but I am
shocked by this information that
personality and charm and you have no
friends your personality and charm
there's always next week for the
personal room and honestly
I think I got them you know after the
challenge I felt like
I should have
taken Direction More I felt like I
should have given my opinion more and if
I would have done that I promise we
would have won the challenge
we're that smart you would have had good
ideas you know what I okay I'm gonna
tell you guys the only fans models take
this I want to be so pissed this is what
I would have did I would have done if if
their thing is dancing right you have to
make it fun for the viewer to watch
because clearly you're a shitty dancer I
mean none of these I mean yeah only fans
women aren't really known for talent
right so you I would have done like a
dance off with bad dancers and that
would have been the tick tock like who
who's a better bad Dan you know
something like that because then it's at
least something fun you know
um I also could have thought of like you
have to add some sort of competition to
make it fun for the viewer unless you
think you're just so hot and pretty that
you can just lip sync which you know
some women are but not them I gotta be
honest like they're I mean they're cute
but it's like that that's really for
like the eight to ten category
so
[Music]
Sophia just understands me she doesn't
really start drama and we just talk
about fun stuff we're here to have
memories and have a good time Kaylee is
such a cutie pie I love her we're gonna
be besties for Life honestly I'm so glad
there's someone here who is so willing
to open up and be her true authentic
self
[Music]
that Tick Tock challenge had me set no
more working with Sophia she's gonna do
her own thing which means I need to do
my own thing so see this there we go the
lack of accountability it's Sophia's
fault it's like when women we have to
take accountability for anything we look
around and say who can I blame and
Sophia was there yeah
[Music]
I'm happy for her she's my friend she's
one of the only people I'm close to here
so yeah I mean I can't sleep in there
for whatever reason I don't know why
she's keeping a room like that but
hang out in there I guess
as crazy how life works you know I'm
really excited to get to know Katana and
have her as a friend throughout my life
I'm like so grateful for this
competition and the girls I know
to our own device
kind of bad people women um like look at
this they're in the house they're gonna
get bored nothing to do so they'll just
start bitching about each other it's
usually how it goes today there's so
long just like lay down
I all to myself
honestly and I can sing in here and
nobody yells at me exactly and if they
try just lock the door exactly like
they're just jealous
foreign
[Music]
I barely got any sleep and I already
have back problems as it is so I was not
happy when I got up that's for sure
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody is pissed off at me because
I'm Singing in the Shower like I'm sorry
that I'm in a good mood that I'm happy
that I'm excited to be I'd be pissed off
at you too I mean how loud you gotta I
mean you could just hum you know like
can you refrain for a week be here and I
just want to you know
[Applause]
singing songs
it looks a lot like my breakfast bar my
last oh really actually that's
unfortunately it's good excuse me a
great selection you're eating my this
has got to be fake I'll I'll entertain
it I mean I do it for the people I'll
entertain it the last breakfast bar and
you're talking to me like that I have
been sleeping in a shed all [__]
night I came here so you know the
breakfast I wanted lost and that's why
you're on the show I'm obsessed that
you're eating my food how entitled are
you I ate katana's last little bar
situation and I guess she was really
upset because she lost and she had to
sleep in the shed
um I don't know why she was so married
to the idea of eating this last bar I
felt enraged
um I think she's a [__] and I don't
know why she feels so entitled to other
people's property whereas there's people
dying look all right I'm gonna do the
I'm gonna give my take on the breakfast
bar let's get over it you know what I
mean it's like you're in the house for a
week okay it's annoying she ate your bar
get over maybe stop it dinner food
that's it it's like all right it's
annoying but whatever you're there a
couple week who cares get over here
okay
she was talking like she was gonna do
something and I was ready for her but
Liliana kept getting in front of me I
tried to stop Naomi but Naomi has her
own mind and we're pretty staged this
has got to be a good friend so I mean it
was pretty crazy uh it was really
intense I don't really know exactly what
they were fighting about but I just
don't really want to get into it so I'm
just gonna stay over here they can stay
over there and hopefully none of the
drama comes to us we have fun
what the [__] are you doing here [__]
get back in the [__] shower where am
I doing I come up here
no one wants to hear that what no one
wants to hear oh because clearly y'all
are getting along so well you were
singing all [__] morning no one could
sleep yeah I'm trying to sing I'm not
trying to kill a [__] in the kitchen I
walk into a major fight they're already
to kill each other and I'm the problem
girl you gotta do some serious
self-evaluation if me singing is the
problem in that scenario do you see this
like gut Ria I know this could be fake I
don't even know but do you see this gut
reaction for them to blame everyone else
I was being annoying therefore everyone
else is the problem I don't know what it
is what is it about us chicks it's like
I was kind of happy that like they fall
and it wasn't just like me fighting
Alyssa all the time because now they
really saw the situation of how it is
these other girls fight about everything
and at the end of the day I get it's a
competition I get we want the money I
know we want to get signed but you also
need to have friends and alliances and
if everyone's just gonna keep fighting
I'm just gonna stick with Kaylee and who
knows we'll probably be the last two
standing and maybe they'll sign us both
together because who doesn't want a pair
of Besties
why why do you guys do this to me
I'm not sure why all of you are fighting
but I need you at the table now
[Music]
the host caught us just in time so
nothing really popped off but she really
overreacted I don't know who raised her
um but I guess the [__] Apple doesn't
fall apart from the [__] tree because
that's unacceptable Behavior
I'm very disappointed in all of you
I'm not sure why you are fighting
fighting snow that
not only in challenges but during your
time here is reflected the at-home
audience will determine if you stay
based on your behavior at the house
with that being said we are going to
start our first main challenge
it is going to be a photo shoot
Challenge and the photographer of this
challenge is going to be so you will
each get 10 minutes to have a
photography session with me whoever has
the best picture will win however I will
have duct tape on my mouth I will not be
able to pose you and I will not be able
to tell you how you could look better in
any given scene you will have to direct
me for every photo we take
with that being said ladies you are all
going to get at least two minutes to
think about what your photos are going
to be like
Sophia you are going to be first
I will see you in two minutes to start
your challenge outside
thank you ladies
[Music]
hi you ready okay
um what if we start right here
[Music]
I had some energy I had some creativity
I had some poses I had some contortion
in there these other girls they got
nothing
[Music]
what are they using oh she is she fat I
didn't even notice wow these other girls
they got nothing I had some contortion
in there these other girls they got
nothing
[Music]
you're so crazy all right all right call
me old-fashioned I consider myself a
commentator whatever but like only fans
models have like one and I I know maybe
there's like some you know it's like
commentators tend to be young women
whatever but it does I know I know guys
require some but only fans you have one
job it's like to be hot and this is what
we got going on like you couldn't starve
yourself for a week like the rest of us
oh dear oh I think uh I think it started
let's go check it out wait who's there
she's having fun but it's fine with me I
don't think that competition is gonna
win honestly I'm curious to see how the
photos came out those are fun
I think even if like this cannot look I
don't know [__] about taking pictures I
I don't I don't not really into
Instagram like that I just kind of you
know do it to post my reels or whatever
but it can't be this
they're not the best they're the most
creative
[Music]
I think they came out pretty well okay
she's got to be that can't be real I
don't I don't believe it hey all right I
know what you're thinking no need to say
it now like you can anyway I look
fabulous so let's take some pictures you
look all right and yes my tan is real
everyone always like wants to know that
so let's see okay this I this can't be
what are you thinking no need to say it
don't say it I always come into every
situation being my son she's at least in
shape like you know I'm loud and I'm
outgoing and I don't have I mean she's
gotta be she's 29. I mean if you're if
you're look at guys guys if the industry
is beauty all right I'm not saying 29
year olds can't do anything but it's
like I mean you're competing with a 19
year old the answers all the time but I
am who I am what you see is what you get
thank you
let's see how we're doing
hmm oh oh that's that's a hard now I
love the photo shoot challenge was
really fun I think all the challengers
are super fun and just you know happy to
be part of it and got to like try
something new so I think it was super
cool
foreign
she's a seasoned Instagram or I can tell
these are like the Instagram poses let's
see how that looks
I think I did well yes I am here to win
so we're gonna make sure this is perfect
for me
we're gonna go ahead and start here
[Music]
that's a that's another seasoned
Instagram I mean I've seen these poses
on Instagram
[Music]
her you know what's so crazy our
forefathers like died for them did the
whole Revolution to start America they
they like went and they fought for our
country so we could have this amazing
country just to have their like great
great great great great granddaughters
do this it's amazing okay
and then we'll go ahead I'm gonna blame
them
[Music]
they could have a time machine and see
what's happening now do you think they
would have 14.
hahaha
yeah I think they'd be like you know
what no thank you I'm not gonna lose my
life for these future holds
they're like maybe the theocracy is
actually okay in England maybe we do
need a king I know I'm gonna win so I
feel happy I don't know how I feel about
the other girls but it's okay
[Music]
wow she has really long arms I mean I
have super long arms so I'm like wow
there's like another one
the photo shoot was super fun
um I do a lot of modeling so it was
really exciting to really
give my own Direction when it comes to
angle I don't trust women that are too
good at pictures and selfies and makeup
because my thought is like how long have
you like looked in the mirror you know
what I mean like you gotta look in the
mirror like you're just looking at
yourself all day it's kind of like I
don't really trust people and I'm sorry
because I think a couple people that
work here do have this I don't remember
who it was but I don't really trust
people that have themselves as their
lock screen it's like why do you what
you just think about yourself all day
like is that you can I remember if it
was you were blessing but it's like yeah
it's like you don't have like a family
or like a kid or like anything you want
to see more than you just you yourself
it really goes back to the me me culture
it's like I just you know I mean I got
one of my sister and me and one of my
parents so it's like they can put their
pictures on their phone they can put
what they can have their pictures as
their own screensaver who's your sisters
and whoever you put on your phone they
could but I don't I don't care it's not
about what they do I'm saying it's my
phone so that's why my picture is on my
screen okay I know that makes me trust
you less I didn't even remember if it
was you to be honest I was like in my I
feel like king would but I'm like it's
not like it's just a picture of me it's
like a motivational picture it has like
my um I'm trying to achieve my boxing
goals and also I put a picture of me
from 2015. well I'm not I'm not talking
about you I'm talking about the the
equivalent so I'm really it's not about
you it's not like that was a direct
attack though no no it wasn't I just
thought as I started saying it I thought
it might apply to you and I was like oh
no but no it's like okay because I'll
see these people with just like pictures
of themselves on their phones and it's
just like you just want to look at
yourself all day and I noticed this
phenomenon years ago like this is really
common I'm just like like nothing not a
friend not a kid not a boyfriend like
it's just you and I just I don't really
so it goes back to this it's like this
Instagram it's like III these girls that
are so good at pictures because I get so
much Flack on Twitter where they're like
learn to take selfies better learn to do
this and it's just like well you got
what you guys don't have better [__] to
do and take pictures of yourself all the
time I'm like but so then these chicks
but yeah so these chicks just come out
modeling maybe King likes take a picture
of what you're doing in your free time
where I think I look the best
on the disappointed
[Music]
and when you're a model you know you're
there to just follow directions so to be
able to give direction was really fun
and I think it turned out great
[Music]
all right so I know you can't talk all
right so I'm gonna start standing so
back I think I like her the best so far
I think she's kind of dumb but I think
she's annoyed me the lead a little bit
one step back perfect I will do
something fun
all right so we'll get down
maybe like try to angle it so it comes
like down a little bit that would be
awesome the photo shoot challenge went
pretty good I had a lot of fun I feel
like I really got to show my personality
in that challenge and that was probably
the most fun challenge for me yeah I
think she's gonna win because she's like
I think she's the most likable I feel
like that you got to be like hamwork but
this could change I'm a woman my
feelings change
[Music]
you can't talk
um I brought this because I'm in a black
bikini so I wanted some color I'm gonna
put it here to make it look a little fun
and I think I was just gonna sit around
it I know it was supposed to be like a
hot challenge but I just wanted to look
friendly nice like I'm having a good
time I didn't want to look too sexy so
I'm not sure if that affected my
position or not but I think my photos
turned out good
[Music]
oh I don't even get to see who won okay
just go to part three I know I just I
want to know who won this who do you
think won I know you're on the edge of
your seat okay don't be salty because I
said the selfie thing who do you think
won
oh don't be don't be salty it wasn't
about you I feel like I feel like you
know you know it was it wasn't about you
wait wait I'm off wait who do you think
won the the challenge so far
karma is a [__] and she got exactly
what was coming to her and I ended up
getting my own room for the week
honestly Liliana needs to change her
attitude I'm like kind of jealous of you
guys because poor girls in one room
that's like having a slumber party every
single night right I'm so excited
cheese maybe she should sleep in the
shower maybe you should you're jealous I
have to sleep on the floor I don't even
get a bed this is oh boo hoo cry me a
river shut up it was really intense I
don't really know exactly what they were
fighting about but I just don't really
want to get into it so I'm just gonna
stay over here they can stay over there
and hopefully none of the drama comes to
us we had fun
because clearly y'all are getting along
so well you were singing all [__]
morning no one could sleep they don't
like it I'm not trying to kill a [__]
in the kitchen I walk into a major fight
they're already to kill each other and
I'm the problem girl you gotta do some
serious self-evaluation if me singing is
the problem in that scenario I was kind
of happy that like they fall and it
wasn't just like me fighting Alyssa all
the time because now they really saw the
situation of how it is but I think my
photos turned out good
foreign
[Music]
I love taking photos I have a pretty
good feeling I'm going to win this
challenge I have trained all three of my
siblings to take my photos for me so
I would consider myself a pro at it
[Music]
foreign
I guess that was the most unique pose
the girl like laying down will give will
give only fans chick credit
[Music]
myself
that was a really fun challenge I'm so
glad for roomies together I know I can't
wait oh my gosh but I really struggle in
that challenge I don't know anything
about this I
job I like use prop
prop it was so fun
girl I am literally so happy that you're
here like seriously you've been one of
my best friends I'm so happy I got to
meet you this stuff has been so crazy I
saw you
it's okay you'll get the next one though
so Naomi like how are you liking your
stare
cool
um it would have been nice to have my
own room but it's whatever right that's
exactly what I feel you see how women
are never happy you get to be you get to
live expense free in a mansion in Miami
and they'll still we are whiners we just
like to whine and complain
it definitely would have been nice to
have our own room but it is
who do you hear someone speaking I think
it's like that old lady over there
anyways
um yeah but it's fun we can have fun
ourselves because you know it's a
friendship where do we live yeah what a
room for girls
yeah it's gonna be fun and we don't
really need any other person that's
going to be toxic or negative you know
okay what are you talking about toxic
you're negative I'm a pissed because you
tried to sabotage my video and it fired
on you backfired on me honey you won
because of me so calm down okay I know
you didn't want me to win you tried to
sabotage my Tick Tock you took my phone
you told me you were taping me and you
taped yourself wasn't this a friendship
so why are you yelling she made it clear
that she wanted an enemy well I felt
like Alyssa was being really ungrateful
and you know all I wanted was a thank
you from her but other than that it was
super good I mean I know I did great so
whatever she did doesn't really matter
you stormed off when I won shows what
kind of friend you are you want aren't
you happy no one likes you now so
congratulations well I guess it's Lonely
at the Top isn't it I guess it is but
you're still gonna leave and go home and
cry so it doesn't really matter
why are you talking though because me
and her were having a conversation and
you just butt in no one wanted you in
this conversation oh I'm sorry I didn't
know I needed you all I can hear in my
head is out of order like when you look
at like Amish chicks and I I use Amish
just because they're the only ones that
aren't crazy because of all this [__]
they're just like these me quiet women
they're super innocent they're giggly
people died for this like I just yeah
you do actually I do yeah you do if you
want you can go to your queen size bed
and be a [__] about it over there and I
want to sit here you know oh well you
don't have to listen to me all right bye
I can actually do what I want you can
okay you can go with your fourth
roommates I will what are they talking
about over there
again
you're right because you say thank you
you know it's so crazy they could just
like walk away you know what I mean
because men like they don't want to
fight well sometimes but but it's like
she could just you know leave the
situation it's a big house how is it
that the two people that hate each other
like end up in the same area it's like
we like the drama we just want to fight
you know listen I was gonna say that you
I was excited when I won stormed off you
armed off because you're a [__] and you
and you have a touch me I love it you
took my phone you're telling me that
you're taping me and you're looking
around at yourself you're literally
yelling out your lungs like a psycho the
psycho that you are so just calm down
I'm a psycho but I'm a [__] winner
girl wear winner to who all I do is win
win no one likes you no one likes you so
you're a winner to who
I appreciate that the whole situation
was very Saucy you see how much how
happy she is it's like we love this
drama but and it's like oh no house full
of Cam women don't like me oh let me
just cry myself to sleep
um Alyssa won but it was really all
because of Liliana
um even though Liliana had her own thing
going on she had her mind set on winning
um and it still helped Alyssa which I
thought was [__] hilarious according
to the [__] challenge I won and I'm
gonna win the next one okay go ahead and
win be lonely and win go ahead I will
rather than I know jealous [__] like
you okay go be to your king size
whatever the [__] bad that you have no
roommates bye [__] love you [__] bye
she won't get any retaliation for me
because I was raised better than that
but okay soon only fans model a cam
model is now telling you how well she
was raised I don't even have to say it I
don't even have to say I'm certainly not
going to find a friend she messed that
up that opportunity I was more than nice
to her I was more than friendly and
trying to get to know her all right who
cares okay she showed me who she really
was so I think that everyone can see
through that I certainly hope the
at-home audience can see through that
all I really wanted like I said was her
to say thank you to me but she literally
made herself look look like a fool in
front of everybody so now everybody
hates her and is going to hate her and
I'm gonna win and I'm gonna be great and
you know I'm friends with everyone so
that's perfect the whole shebang was
very entertaining like I I thought they
were gonna throw at least she admits it
fans I was ready for it but it didn't
happen so I guess they weren't about it
but it's whatever honestly I don't
understand why yes I understand it's a
competition but we can all be friends
and then we this is so much more fun
um guys that never works women like
cannot be friends with each other I mean
not without not without bitching like I
mean we could be friends with each other
and then fall out and then be friends
again and then fall out and then be
friends like that's just how we work I
don't know why yeah I don't know maybe
we could talk to them and everybody can
yeah I don't know I cannot stand her can
I girl don't even start with Liliana
no we need to get her out oh my gosh she
has just been so rude since the moment
she showed up like every word that comes
out of her mouth is like girl just stop
talking she just starts [__] with
everyone I don't know we gotta do
something about her I think they're
extra for no reason I think Alyssa is
loud and annoying and she needs to get
out immediately maybe more so than Naomi
and that's saying something I think
they're a disturbance to the house I
think liliana's just here to win and be
a [__] to everyone and I don't like it
it's just too much bad energy for me we
need to form an alliance and get her out
of here honestly because we if we're
talking like this we can be the only
girls that don't like her oh yeah okay
so first of all oh my gosh this is what
chicks do they like get into an alliance
but it's so weird because I feel like if
guys don't like someone they're not
gonna go around and get everyone else to
not like them they just kind of fight it
out or avoid them whatever women it's
like we we do social social violence so
we'll get everyone in the group to not
like um talk [__] you know it's me and
you so it's me and you against these
other [__] and let's just see what
happens we're gonna make it to the end
you got this well I'm pretty tired of
all the drama we heard them fighting and
we were just like oh my gosh so we
decided to form an alliance we want to
stay away from all that drama at the end
of the day it's a competition so it's
where we're at I think it sparked
something not only in me but also in her
everyone saw us as a good girls because
we didn't really fight I used my
fighting words back here where no one
can hear these girls better watch out
because there's some plots coming
oh
all right ladies come on in for your
first day challenge
[Music]
all right everyone so today is going to
be an endurance challenge all of you are
going to have to do a plank for as long
as possible oh my gosh I used to do
these in college with the volleyball
team we did plank till you tank I wonder
if any of them are gonna be able to I
don't want to say what I got because I'm
going to be really mad if someone beat
me oh I'll tell I'll say it I got I
think it was like four minutes and like
30 something seconds back in the day
roughly Miami Heat
so on the count of three you will all
get into a plank position if you fall
you cannot get back up you must lay and
wait and see who is going to be the
winner there's a girl I think the
highest we got on the team was like
eight or nine minutes so she that was
and I was like second or third but yeah
I couldn't do that the winner will be
free from eliminations this week are you
all ready
all right go ahead and lay down and when
I say go you will assume your plank
position
all right
ready
set
go
I already know that fat chick's going
down first I already know
[Music]
who looks in the best shape she's kind
of athletic
now she won't I don't know if she's
athletic or
um no I don't like her
[Music]
I bet she went she looks like the most
athletic a lot of them just are like
just look like they're like naturally
thin she's 29 she's gotta work for it
you want to guess anyone
thank you
[Music]
but let me tell you this Miami Heat is
nothing to play with I felt like I was
out there baking why did I put shea
butter on before I did that challenge I
don't know
um but that definitely wow the fat the
fat chick out did her wow that's
surprising that didn't help me so losing
was definitely a bummer because I see
myself as pretty fit but whatever that
one didn't pan out yeah I didn't think
she'd win I thought she'd get like close
though I thought it would
no way no way
okay okay
I wanna be able to say how many seconds
honestly I thought I could win that one
but at the end of the day my arms just
gave out honestly I've been hitting the
gym a little too much lately so I blame
that
yeah I'm still she's got a word that
everyone else is oh no she's gonna fall
they put the camera on her
ah dang it I was rooting for you we're
all rooting for you
I was a little disappointed that I
didn't win the playing challenge but you
can't win them all I was really just
happy that I had my own room so not
winning the playing challenge wasn't the
end of the world because I know I will
have my opportunity
I didn't win the plank challenge but I
got pretty far and I won the photo shoot
so I know I'm fine but I can't say a lot
for Liliana and Naomi and our winner
thank you so much Kaylee you are the
winner of today's challenge
you all did a great job but Kaylee will
be the only one free from eliminations
this week thank you all and you can take
the rest of the day to yourselves I'm
very happy about that
um I would say I'm pretty athletic so I
was excited about a fitness challenge
and I didn't mean to upset anybody by
winning but I'm happy I'm happy I'm safe
from elimination
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
guys hello this is a side note but I
like it yo guys this isn't [__] funny
is anybody still here are you [__]
kidding me all of the girls saw me
sleeping on the couch because I was
ready before everybody else and I just
you know it's a long few days here those
Challengers are daunting so I'm just
with your challenges of doing wait let
me let me get this straight a tick tock
some pictures and a plane wore you out
it's so crazy like our grandmothers were
farmers they like plowed Fields they
like made butter from scratch like
trying to take a nap and not one of them
woke me up and at first I'm like what
the [__] is wrong with these girls like
that is so shady that is so malicious
first of all you have to purposely walk
in absolute silence okay like a group of
girls all talking like I know these
girls they're not quiet girls and to go
out of your way to make sure I don't
wake up that is Shady that is Shady and
that shows who they really are okay I
don't need to be malicious and mean to
try to win you can like dislike me
because I have a lot of personality and
I like to talk and I like to get to know
to people but to purposely leave
somebody out that's just like mean girl
energy and we're not about that
I'm not sorry she is loud she chimes in
every chance she gets she won't let
anyone else get a word in the
conversation we made the right choice it
doesn't surprise me at all that Liliana
was the one to tell everyone to leave me
behind and be quiet I know that she has
a lot of Mean Girl energy going on I
know that she purposely does not like me
even though I did nothing to her I went
out of my way to try to be friends with
her and she's still trying to sabotage
me I think she feels a little dumb and a
little foolish after The Tick Tock
Challenge and how that completely
backfired that's a that's a her issue
that's not a me issue
wait
um well they have their own minds if
they decided to listen to me is because
I'm right obviously I mean it was
Alyssa's fault I mean I don't know why
she doesn't have an alarm on her phone
or something it's her fault not mine all
of liliana's problems with I like how
there's a consistent theme okay nobody's
it's nobody's fault that's what
everybody if you ask women no no we have
zero fault in anything whoever we can
blame and honestly the way I think it's
like well if I fell asleep I would just
blame myself I'd be annoyed but I was
like I didn't blame myself oh well I
could I could have woke her it's like
who raised these people probably no one
me stem from her own shortcomings and
insecurities and have nothing to do with
me so it does not surprise me at all
that she told all the girls to be quiet
and let me sleep through the dinner you
can't win by making everyone else late
it just makes you look bad because you
took so long
um I I did feel really bad but I was
just kind of following the crowd and
they all told me to leave so and this
shows we just do what everyone else does
we don't really have we just kind of go
with what everyone else is doing I just
had to go with it I didn't want to start
any drama in myself like if I would have
woken her up I feel like there would
have been a big fight so I just kind of
went with it I can explain everything to
our leader when we got home but yeah I
don't know I feel really bad about it
I'm just having so much fun in this
competition and being around all these
awesome girls I felt so bad that we
didn't we left her out and she wasn't
part of the experience with us so I do
feel a little bit bad at the end of the
day I hope she will forgive us for that
and it doesn't affect our friendship
Liliana is a bully and she's gonna make
those girls feel bad she's gonna peer
pressure them
um which kind of just shows like our
nature she's gonna make them feel a
certain peer pressure guilt yeah because
that's just how we are kind of go with
whatever
wants that's how a bully operates so I
don't hold it against the other girls I
know who Liliana is and I know what her
MO is and it's I would absolutely hold
it against the other chicks I mean like
in some sense if you felt betrayed and
they went along with it yeah they're not
your friends they are not very clear
what she's trying to do and what she's
all about I'm here to win and if that
makes me win then yeah I'm forming into
lines but I mean it's not on purpose you
know we're still friends I hope so hello
ladies and thank you for this week we
know that it's been hard on you this is
the naked Taco enjoy your stay while
you're here and if you need anything we
will be around
thank you
[Music]
so the photo shoot was so much fun yeah
I had a blast everyone did so good yeah
I think so oh no a couple of the girls
are saying that Sophia didn't do so hot
yeah like you could do any better your
snooze Fest over there no Personality
yeah okay where's all this attitude like
you dress like a model and yeah you make
me want to follow us you're out there
making out with pants looking crazy but
you know what at least I can come up
with ideas
nobody here really came up guys why do
you torture me with this I'm just this
is bad act I I mean I actually it's so
crazy I think that I think they might be
serious what do you like it's so funny
our grandmothers had like seven children
that's like what they were doing we're
just going on what ideas yeah they're
doing this [__] because I do the [__]
for real really
you cannot talk to my best friend like
that I really did because hell no you're
not going after my girl like that [__]
this and talk to you yeah okay whatever
nobody cares whatever Naomi can just
suck it she's not gonna make a bar in
this competition because she's so
forgettable
what what did I get from this photo
shoot competition
everyone was talking about me everyone
knows who I am and honestly I caught
people's attention hers no one's talking
about hers because it was boring I
wasn't just gonna let her sit there and
think that she did an amazing job when
there are other girls who clearly saw
that she didn't do that great everybody
was yelling I think I got way out of
hand and I knew we had to get out of
that situation and we're not going to
entertain that type of behavior so I
just got her out of a very bad situation
and we're coming up with a plan we have
everything taken care of and I think
their plans suck like their sabotage is
a [__] missing dinner it's like we're
so bad at everything guys we can't even
sabotage right oh this is so
embarrassing it'll work in our paper
so I'm starting to feel a little bad
that we left Alyssa behind why don't
feel bad you don't like her she's part
of the group no she's not trust me
you're just lying to yourself you don't
sort of no she's not I don't know we had
such a fun time that wasn't cool we left
her behind I think it was you're fine
you're gonna win don't worry I'm gonna
win too so well I just didn't want any
problems I wanted it to be all good
vibes I didn't want anybody to be mad at
each other so I guess it felt kind of
good I mean not good that everybody's
fighting but I feel like I did my part
and I tried to keep the peace so it is
what it is it was kind of I don't think
Sophia or anybody deserves any type of
that behavior so she was I don't know I
think she just took it too far and I
think she needs to leave I think Caitlyn
was being really dramatic I don't know
why Caitlyn thinks like we really care
about her emotions like
I don't know Alyssa and Caitlyn they're
both dumb blondes but I mean it is what
it is that Everyone likes me and that's
what matters I was just trying to have a
good time I had my drink I was fine you
know they can fight if they want but
there was good food good drinks good
friends it was just a show to me
foreign
ladies and welcome to elimination you
have all been judged based on your
challenges this week as well as the
at-home audience has been judging your
every move in the house I have seen some
of you form clicks and alliances these
may help you moving forward however if
the at-home audience does not like it it
will affect your scoring
by the end of your time here whoever is
in first placed based on their overall
score will win the cash prize and the
signing to Yum Model Management
when I call your name you are going to
step forward and you are going to be
safe from elimination this week
Kaylee you are safe
I feel good I feel safe like I can't get
eliminated this week but I don't know
like I don't want anyone to come after
Sophia and I'm going to protect her as
best as I can Naomi you are safe this
week
[Music]
I don't feel like I'm in the red I think
I've done everything that I need to do
you see the theme it's like we're all so
amazing everyone else is anonymous to
stand out and to be who I am which is
strong independent and of course of
course after that with Alyssa you are
safe this week
[Music]
I am not really concerned about
eliminations because at the end you know
it's interesting all these shows reward
the worst types of women I mean it's
like all the women that are fighting are
the ones that are the safe first okay I
came here and I should and really that's
just Society like rewards bad behavior
who I am I brought my energy I brought
my personality I tried to bring a little
life into this otherwise dull household
and if the other girls or the at-home
audience doesn't like me for that well
at least I'm getting eliminated being
who I am katana
you are safe
[Music]
I think most of them yeah I like to
think I'm a pretty neutral personality
I'm not too loud I'm not too quiet and I
hope everyone likes what I bring to the
table
and
Caitlyn you are safe
[Music]
I believe I can win this competition so
I'm just gonna I don't know if she's
gonna win anymore I think he might need
more like personality than she has keep
my smile on and say a prayer that leaves
Liliana and Sophia Sophia you did not do
well in your photo shoot challenge but
your at-home audience loves your
personality
well I'll be really sad I think people
are always going to remember me I have
unique hair a personality that shines
brighter than the sun oh my I'm so
special I'm willing to speak my mind
that's what we need more only fans
models just willing to speak their mind
and I don't blend into any crowds I am
not conforming to anything or anyone's
standards I think I did my job and the
audience will know who I am people I did
amazing out there will know who I am so
I hope as long as I get the attention
that I need as long as I get the
attention I don't care if I win who
cares about money they're not stupid
enough to send me home but if they are
I'm sure I'll be fine I'll get signed
with plenty of people I think
everything's gonna turn out okay for me
it'll turn out amazing I'm translating
guys
Liliana you did okay at each challenge
you were given however your at-home
audience did not enjoy your personality
towards the other girls in the house I
know I'm gonna win so I don't really
care but I mean it's gonna be amazing I
am amazing I mean I'm gonna feel kind of
bad for the other girls because I'm
going home I'm gonna have to like fake a
tear or something of course they like me
who wouldn't like me I mean I I am
awesome bring them coffee in the morning
you know I am always saying hi and
making sure that like our energies yeah
I think they're gonna send this one home
always match I'm so nice to them why
wouldn't they like me of course they
like and for that reason Liliana
thank you
[Music]
we'll be our loser for this week
place in mind that this means that you
have a greater chance of losing this
competition at the end of your time here
at the house
thank you ladies and I will see you next
week
wow I was on the edge of my seat all
right guys
um I think I lost brain cells watching
that um let me know if you like these
reactions only fans models competing
favorite my favorite thing just so
amazing uh let me know what you think
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel I'll talk to you next
time